hey happy birthday
nerd of many things
if i win a game 37 moves or 84 moves
you'll donate that many dollars okay
let's win in 84 moves or 37 moves
wait i feel inspired to
win in an
arbitrary number of moves now
that's such an odd request
i feel like i should go for 84.
but that requires having a long game
hi
and not flagging my opponent
hi
to alec finn
i mean maybe i should go for 37 because
it comes sooner
than 84.
what if i win in like 20 moves
okay let's as long as we don't lose
i guess that's the first step
oh that's a fancy move
uh
i have to be sad i guess
oh my thing
i might win on time in 37 moves how
would that work
does that still count as a win
oh no
opponents too slow
i'm gonna win sooner
we need seven more moves
ah there's 36 moves i was trying to give
them time to pre-move too
oh
i've never been so close to so much
money
oh
oh i feel bad
that was such a unfortunate game too
opponent played well
i just played a little bit too slowly
okay let's try again i guess
um
yeah the problem is most people aren't
fast enough to play 84 moves
in one minute
so 37 is probably the number to hit
i mean the problem is here i'm yeah i'm
gonna
i'm already kind of winning
i have to just win more slowly than
usual
let's castle
i've never tried to like time a win for
a certain move number
this feels wrong
but also kind of fun
let's be careful here
oh that's a good move
i've made in one but that's only 34.
god 35 moves
i was certainly made in two as well i
was so excited that like white would
play this
and then it would be check here and then
mate on move 37 with a pawn
i know i missed mate
did i miss me earth i missed me earlier
too yeah
um
of course
yeah b4 would be a nice mate immediately
as long as i keep winning i'll keep
berserking
opponent doing some weird stuff
i'm trying to punish this opening
running bishop f4
and now it's writing main one
expecting i was expecting rook h7
um okay i'll take
i could have taken an e6
that's okay though
or is it
my time is kind of low
you
84 moves
let's go
i won in 84 moves
almost flagged there too
i should have just delivered mate but
i won in 84 moves
um
yeah that challenge was like from at
least an hour ago
but now i feel accomplished
whoa it's nerd of many things thank you
so
much
oh thank you